Imagine it’s 1957 and you’re a high-ranking
official with the British Army, responsible
for keeping the West free from Soviet aggression.
At your disposal you have a great arsenal,
both conventional and nuclear, as well as
teams of brilliant scientists at the Royal
Armament Research and Development Establishment
constantly proposing ideas for new, more effective
weapons.
One of your areas of greatest strategic concern
is the possibility that the Soviet Union might
make inroads sufficiently into Western Europe
to bring its advanced rockets and bombs within
range of the British Isles.
Recall that during World War II, Germany bombed
the snot out of Britain with tens of thousands
of bombs dropped from Luftwaffe aircraft,
as well as more than 10,000 long-range V-1
and V-2 cruise and ballistic missiles shot
from sites in France and the Netherlands.
Deciding that the best way to keep the Soviets
from your doorstep is a scorched earth policy,
to “deny occupation of the area to an enemy
for an appreciable time,” you choose from
all your options that blowing any invaded
areas in West Germany to smithereens using
nuclear weapons is the best alternative.
After all, this not only destroys enemy troops
and denies them access to valuable infrastructure,
but also makes the area around the explosion
uninhabitable for some time after.
Not content to rely on gravity bombs or missiles,
your crack team concludes that nuclear landmines
(that could either be placed on the surface,
buried or even submerged in rivers and lakes)
are the way to go.
You settle on a 16,000 pound tub that resembles
an enormous boiler from the outside, but inside
hosts a large nuclear warhead and two firing
units, with the design partially based on
your country’s first operation nuke- the
Blue Danube.
With a predicted yield of ten kilotons, each
bomb would create an estimated crater of 375
feet across for a surface blast and 640 feet
if detonated 35 feet below ground.
Versatile, the device could either be detonated
by timer (capable of being set as far as eight
days in advance), directly with a wire from
up to 3 miles away, or simply detonated automatically
if any of several anti-tampering devices were
activated.
Sold!
blur-peacockThis is exactly what happened.
In July of 1957, the British Army Council
order 10 of these so-called Blue Peacock nuclear
landmines.
However, the designers of the bomb foresaw
a problem.
The bomb’s sensitive components had to be
kept at a certain temperature, far above the
average of mid-Europe in winter.
They also had to be kept at that temperature
for potentially several days after an invasion
and subsequent deployment of the nuclear mines.
At this point the boy-wonders floated a couple
of options for warming the device.
By far the most interesting proposal was to
place a coop filled with chickens and seed
inside the bomb before deploying it.
The chickens could survive in such conditions
for at least a week- plenty of time for enemy
troops to approach after the nuke was deployed.
And, critically, the chicken’s body heat
would maintain the proper temperature, while
the coop itself would (hopefully) keep them
from pecking at the delicate equipment inside.
Perhaps realizing how absolutely ridiculous
the chicken idea is (although not the only
viable bird-brained bomb idea to come out
of this era- or, more likely, realizing the
risks of nuclear fallout on neighboring, allied
populations (and political fallout once West
Germany realized what the British had done
to their homeland, invaded or not), in February
of 1958, the MoD Weapons Policy Committee
scrapped the project.
However, two inert prototypes were retained,
and one still exists today, although the public
remained blissfully unaware of it until 2004,
when Operation Blue Peacock was declassified
and included in a National Archives exhibition.
Given that the exhibit opened on April 1st
and a critical suggested component of the
nuclear mines was chickens, more than a few
people thought that Blue Peacock was an elaborate
joke – forcing the National Archives to
put out an official statement that while “it
does seem like an April Fool . . . it most
certainly is not.
The Civil Service does not do jokes.”